amanda how do you know if a joke works
or not if sometimes
this is so funny we actually talked
about this in
uh my coaching session with josiah today
how do you know if a joke works or not
joke works
or um let me try it again amanda
how do you know if a joke works or not
if works sometimes and then doesn't work
other times
a joke is really a law of averages
um kind of like how people ask well how
do you know when to kill a joke
it's like well after like 10 20 times of
trying it if it doesn't work
go ahead and throw it to the side don't
necessarily get rid of it or kill it
but just put it on a shelf that you can
revisit later on
so for a joke to work sometimes and not
the other
take into consideration
what the setting of the show is where it
works versus when it doesn't
i always before my show i go through a
pre-show
checklist and this is something i've i
talk about in the writing course based
on like
judging a room is like
okay what time is it what day is it
who are the people in the audience is it
primarily comics
is this a comedy venue versus a pub that
most people didn't even know there was
going to be
comedy how is the audience responding to
other comics
these are all kind of factors that'll
play into the response you get and how
to
gauge it when you're grading your set so
i would
say if a joke works sometimes and not
be mindful of when it does work what is
that
setting versus when it doesn't work what
is that setting and when you listen back
to your set
maybe you said it one way that made it
work
whether it was a certain phrasing it was
a
certain way how you said it versus when
it didn't work
maybe you were tired and you said with a
little less enthusiasm or maybe
you skipped over a word and you missed
the proper
wording of the setup to get to that
punch line or maybe you flubbed on the
punch line
so there's a so many different factors
but if a joke works sometimes and
doesn't the other there's usually
some sort of smoking gun there's usually
some sort of reason behind it working
whether it is the setting
or it is how you said the joke
so it could be the setting or the
setting
but that that should help you to
actually narrow down
when does it work how can i make sure it
works more times or when it doesn't work
how can i avoid that in the future
great question though great question
though it all comes down to
trying it several times recording that
reviewing it refining hey hop brother
and sister
if you enjoyed this comedy tip subscribe
to this youtube channel and go
join our facebook group to have your
questions answered live
on next week's q a